on va parler d'un sujet tout autre est
un peu plus léger alors c'est de
monsieur françois de rugy qu'il s'agit
de ces dîners qui ne font pas bon ménage
avec la république exemplaire
non seulement ces dîners mais aussi les
travaux qu'il a pu entreprendre dans
l'appartement privé du ministère de
l'écologie on va parler tout ça il y
aurait eu une dizaine de dîner dit
médiapart entre octobre 2017 et juin
la question se pose de sa démission
il n'a pas exclu lui-même françois de
rugy d'avoir commis des erreurs
d'appréciation l'écoutent c'était ce
matin il était en déplacement très
attentif à ce que toutes les
explications soit donnée est que si avec
des personnalités extérieures comme la
déontologue de l'assemblée par exemple
ça peut être d'autres formules il y
avait à des vérifications à faire
je suis tout prêt à me livrer ici il ya
eu des erreurs d'appréciation de ma part
je serais tu prêt également à l'école ça
fait partie c'est normal ce sont les
comptes que l'on doit rendre aux
français ils étaient dans les deux sets
ce matin il a dû rentrer plus tôt que
prévu à paris convoquée dit on à
matignon
faut dire alors on va on va on va
écouter également ce qu'ils disaient
hier matin en attendant et puisque c'est
notre sujet principal doit-il
démissionner on entend sur ce point la
députée delphine batho aux non inscrits
aujourd'hui mais ancien proche des
écologistes elle dit que selon elle la
situation pour françois de rugy est
intenable
un ministre est particulièrement un
ministre de l'écologie pour gagner un
certain nombre d'arbitrages face à un
certain nombre de lobby doit être en
situation d'autorité et l'autorité de
l'état des ministres
elle est notamment dans leur moralité
c'est la raison pour laquelle la
situation dans laquelle il est est
intenable et il ne veut pas rester
membre du gouvernement alors situation
intenable vous êtes nombreux à le penser
puisque à la question du jour sur le
site du figaro cette pole man vous êtes
pour le moment 90% à dire que françois
de rugy doit démissionner
le red bull on sait pas si vous avez un
opinion personnelle sur la démission non
mais déjà sur la sphère elle-même alors
sur la démission je n'ai pas d'opinion
je le dis tout de suite je pense que
c'est des arbitrages à rendre par
d'autres personnes que moi et je suis
contente de pas être à leur place sur la
façon dont on reçoit cette histoire
comme citoyen la première chose à dire
c'est qu'évidemment c'est très choquant
fin et dans le contexte de protestation
sociale qu'on connaît ces temps ci de se
dire que on dépense de l'argent public à
faire des dîners de luxe
évidemment on est très choquée de même
que quand le canard enchaîné révèle que
raymond barre avait un compte en suisse
on s'étrangle un peu quoi et donc ses jo
avec cette question de 2,2 manque
d'exemplarité ou du manque de probité de
nos représentants et des membres du
gouvernement c'est un peu angoissant
deuxième réaction quand même on en a un
peu marre de vivre sous ce régime du
scandale permanent ou quoi c'est à dire
que le régime de révélations qui se
succèdent en accéléré et que en fait
toutes les personnes publiques sont
exposés au fait qu'on fouille sans arrêt
dans leur vie publique et privée pour
trouver de quoi les salir les fragilise
et moi ça alors nous pencher pour
qu'elle la première partie votre nom est
alors juste un troisième point je sais
que je pense qu'il ya un paradoxe sur la
nouvelle transparence qu'on exige donc
on avait à la revue esprit et mener un
entretien très intéressant avec rené
dosière cet ancien député qui a bien
bossé sur la moralisation de la vie les
bébés voilà qui a imposé notamment créé
un budget à l'elysée et c'est là et rené
dosière explique très bien c'est un
paradoxe en fait ya jamais eu autant de
transparence qu'aujourd'hui on n'a
jamais été si bien informé sur les
finances publiques sur qui dépense quoi
et c'est pour ça aussi qu'on découvre
des choses qu'on savait pas avant et
donc on a l'impression que c'est pire
qu'avant alors que en réalité sans doute
plus dans un lieu juste à l'écouté parce
que lauren nous disait il ya eu raymond
barre et montbard c'était il ya 40
oui mais c'est un risque que ce n'était
pas dîner de la république s'est pas
exactement
je suis au fond c'est ça c'est pas un
peu plus grave que le d'organiser au
noir bien que de manger du homard c'est
pas bien aux périodes de gilet jaune
j'en conviens quand on est à un euro 7
mai d'abord françois de rugy
j'imagine qu'il n'est pas le seul à
faire ce genre de choses donc déjà on a
d'un seul coup tu désigner le coupable
idéal alors effectivement il s'est fait
gauler il faut t'il alerte sur la photo
sur la photo il est ravi de la crèche
c'est absolument les détruire avec avec
si ses pétales de roses tout ça est
totalement grotesque j'en conviens mais
moi je m'inquiète
cette civilisation du poisson rouge pour
par parler du livre de patino et qui
consiste à faire de la transparence un
outil de destruction démocratique
ça me terrorise pourquoi je vous dis ça
parce que la transparence avec
l'accumulation de données elle ne peut
pas exister
plus il ya la formation et - la
transparence n'existe est-ce que je
explique ces cons on est en train de
confondre une vitre qui nous permettrait
de regarder la vie publique avec des
loupes porté sur des tout petits détails
de la vie publique
c'est certes peut-être un gros d'état et
vu des vues du français qui ne vit pas
comme ça j'en suis tout à fait d'accord
si françois de rugy doit démissionner à
cause de cette histoire à la limite pour
3 ans de régime je m'en moque
la réalité c'est que la démocratie on
aura encore pris un coup dans les
carreaux et c'est ça qui me fait très
peur on est dans une situation de la
dénonciation si mediapart feu comme
d'autres s'amuser à cela ça rappelle les
pires heures de ce pays où la
dénonciation régnait en maître dictature
de la transparence qui pavera va trop
loin
guillaume bigot c'est à dire qu'il ya un
risque de n'être de vous choquer cette
question de la corruption même de la
corruption appelant un chat un chat
c'est pas un sujet politique majeur
lorsque les dirigeants politiques sont à
la hauteur des circonstances et servent
en fait la population servent les états
servent les peuples quant à léran
signalé des traités il le faisait au nom
de la france il servait vraiment les
intérêts de la france est rempli c'est
aussi les caisses de la france on sait
bien qu'il se servait tout le monde
savait que servat au passage est en fête
je crois même que ces traités étaient
tarifées briller même un tarif en face
donc il est il en mangeait beaucoup du
homard je pense mais c'était à léran
donc il servait la france il servait
l'état et il servait le pays
là ce qui est vraiment vraiment pénible
c'est qu'ils n'ont plus que ça à nous
vendre c'est à dire leur transparence
est alors plus ils nous vendent leur
transparence et vit évidemment plus
quand ils sont attrapés ça fait un effet
contrasté effectivement très très gênant
mais c'est c'est lorsque il ya deux ya
deux affirmations ils ne servent pas le
pays et ils se servent et la deuxième
n'est vraiment insupportable que parce
que la première n'est plus en place en
fait en quelque sorte le ministre n'est
pas à la hauteur du cou il est encore
plus susceptibles d'être attaqués
marc landré c'est une bonne ça c'est une
bonne approche
il ya il ya eu d'exemplarité qui est
exigé qui est mise en avant par nos
politiques bailly c'est un bon moment
pour ça me fait penser à françois fillon
qui avait été droit dans ses bottes sont
la campagne présidentielle il est tombé
par là où il a péché c'était soi-disant
il aurait pris vie écrit reprochable il
n'était pas irréprochable il est tombé
rhji c'est pareil rappelons nous quand
même de qui on parle français d'origine
il a fait à peu près tous les partis
politiques avant d'arriver là où il est
il a fait la primaire de la gauche en
jurant la main sur le coeur et en
signant sur la bible qui sera celle
inverse qu'ils se rallieraient aux
candidats de la primaire pour sitôt la
prime est retourné à l'ehess rallier à
emmanuel macron il a été un très mauvais
présidents de l'assemblée nationale et
tout le monde
tous les députés y compris ton provocant
sont très content qu'il soit parti
il n'y a pas grand monde aujourd'hui
pour le défendre non pas parce qu'il a
fait mais parce que peut-être il ne le
mérite pas donc le problème il ya c'est
que quand on veut laver plus blanc que
blanc va quand on a une tâche ça se voit
plus je m'interroge donc justement sur
le fait qu'il ya eu toute cette campagne
sous jacente contre lui qui d'un seul
coup prendre l'ampleur parce que les
photos short ses passifs à ce qui fait
courir cette mauvaise politique si ce
n'est de manger du homard voir et vous
vous êtes déjà allés dîner du soir dans
des ministères
ils s'étaient payés par le contribuable
moi aussi c'est le problème est pas là
le problème c'est que ça se voit ça se
sache et que quand on ne saurait que
pourra alimenter votre débat notre débat
je voudrais qu passe cet extrait
effectivement des explications données
par françois de rugy hier et qui en un
sens nous fait sans doute que l'enfoncer
ça faisait partie de mon travail de
président de l'assemblée nationale de
rencontres et de représenter d'ailleurs
aussi l'assemblée d'expliquer ce que
nous faisions à l'assemblée de défendre
l'assemblée nationale auprès de gens de
la société civile
c'est normal moi je l'assumé totalement
on reproche souvent aux hommes et aux
femmes politiques d'être coupé de noeux
d'être que dans leur monde politique d
dans une forme de bulle politique
et bien moi j'ai toujours souhaité que
l'assemblée nationale soit ouvert de
consultants vous pouvez conseillez ce
type de personnage
xavier couture l'argument dire c'était
pour pas se couper de la société civile
cissé d'une maladresse infâme non mais
je ne peux pas dû il est indéfendable
dire que je ne sais pas qui lui a donné
ses éléments de langage pour parler
comme un consultant
mais c'est effectivement très très
maladroit c'est horriblement maladroit
maj a dénoncé quelque chose qui était de
l'ordre général qui est c'est ce
principe de transparence qui amène à ce
que l'on finisse par confondre la la
transparence et les loupe mais en
l'occurrence en l'espèce
françois de rugy à la fois sur les
photos sur le processus qui a amené à ce
qu'elle soit révélée et la manière dont
il se défend
il s'est évidemment tragique c'est
pathétique et je le reconnais et je ne
comprends pas pourquoi il n'a pas
simplement dit que l'assemblée avait une
tradition
d'apparence d'apparat et que les dîners
avait lieu comme cela qu'il en était
tout à fait heureux j'aurais assumé les
choses de manière différente à sa place
je ne serais pas lancé dans cette bulle
dans laquelle ils voulaient échapper
pour se remettre dans une bulle de omaha
des bulles de champagne enfin un ordre
on est honnête aux confins du ridicule
surtout qui a un côté supplice chinois
là les noms des invités vont sortir on
va
décortiquer savoir si oui ou non ils
sont que des imprécateurs d'ailleurs si
je peux me permettre
on a un monsieur aphatie par exemple qui
ne cesse de faire la morale publique en
permanence comme par hasard il y est
voyez c'est quand même assez curieux
plier passe sur twitter il a regretté
d'y aller quelques réactions
by smart pour moi il ne doit pas
démissionner car si tel était le cas ils
doivent être nombreux à démissionner
c'est pratique dure sans aucun doute
depuis aussi longtemps que notre
république
mais même avant probablement vous
parliez de talleyrand fred il doit
démissionner et rembourser nicole ce qui
est insupportable n'ai pas de temps
l'utilisation notre argent comme si
c'était le leur mais leur côté donneur
de leçons et babineau ne dit le
comportement de de rhji et scandaleux sa
crédibilité ne fera pas long feu pour la
place d'emmanuel macron et d'edouard
philippe il faut couper vite la branche
ou pas je crois qu'il l'a matignon
l'état matignon d'après ce qu'on sait
ouais donc il en est il en est entré il
y entre et à 16h30 qu'il y ait toujours
c'est visiblement ça dure
j'en sais rien il ya un côté il ya un
côté alors un peu parallèle devos qui
vaut mes affaires benalla le feuilleton
de l'été qui doit être sera peut-être le
running gag généralement quand quand
mediapart comment tu rentres ses crocs
dans quel cas il le lâche pas donc
probablement qu'il y aura une salle veut
de 1 épisode 2 épisode 3 épisodes 4 et
peut-être qu'effectivement il faut
couper la branche le plus tôt possible
pour pas que ça fasse comme l'été
dernier cas quand même pourri la rentrée
des miels macro avec la sphère benalla
mais malheureusement on n'en sait rien
enfin moi m'a fait lire dire qu'il
vienne me chercher sur origin sera
résolu avant
citoyen payeur nous dit ce n'est pas par
hasard s'il est convoqué par edouard
philippe en fin d'après-midi pour
annonce de démission au 20h le plan
médiatique et peut-être supprimer ah non
pardon ça c'est un commentaire qui était
supprimée c'est pas sûr non nos pneus
d'ici le gouvernement tente de le sauver
comme il continue de le faire avec
benalla se passe les entraîner vers le
fond
surtout que mediapart doit encore avoir
des cartouches
il ya aussi cette dimension politique il
est assez pour le souligner il est assez
seul françois de rugy on peut pas dire
qu'il ait beaucoup de troupes derrière
lui saha transfuge il n'a pas il n'a pas
vraiment devant une solidarité qui
s'exprime autour de lille est bien dans
le casting il pense oui mais non ils
pensent qu'en même temps il pense pas du
tout il est d'accord avec tout le monde
est dans l'air du temps il est
complètement dans le casting
soyons clairs c'est ça le problème c'est
là aucun moment les tous les ministres
les dirigeants en général ont des
privilèges ont accès à du luxe ont accès
pas c'est pas un bond de l'isra qui
choque en fait le problème c'est la
contrepartie noblesse n'oblige plus avec
c'est quoi la contrepartie de sarov est
alors maintenant le seul argument qui
vient d'avancer la transparence c'est à
dire qu'en fait bon nous ne faisons pas
grand chose mais au moins nous ne sommes
prob
bah non en fait non ça ne suffit pas
lohan lorraine end arrive juste un mot
pour défendre le gouvernement une fois
n'est pas coutume il me semble que
jusqu'ici quand il ya eu des cas un peu
semblable la sphère des assistants
parlementaires européens pour le modem
etc
la ligne mâcon philippe a toujours été
plus ou moins la même c'est-à-dire
d'abord solidarité avec les membres du
gouvernement c'est nos ministres on les
abandonne pas donc là on est dans cette
séquence
et puis dans un deuxième temps qui
arrive assez vite en effet la première
loi qu'on a fait passer c'était une loi
de moralisation de la vie publique
cette position n'est pas tenable il doit
partir il s'en va donc on va voir ce qui
se passe ce soir mais jusque là ils ont
eu la même attitude plus ou moins sûr
tous les quinze ans de la ce en même
temps à le retrouver dès ce matin dans
les propos de benjamin griveaux on va
l'écouter
il était l'invité de rmc josé manuel les
montants chaud quand je vous lis dit je
vous lis et le comportement de juger le
comportement bon se jouer les manchots
vous y retrouverez pas chez moi à coeur
d'un donneur de leçon ou deux leçons de
morale pour conclure c'est choquant mais
en fait pas de morale aux garçons qui
est secrétaire d'état auprès de françois
de rugy
on peut pas dire que ce matin qu'elle
les dénonce